we know that several antibiotics work on
bacteria by blocking their transcription
or translation process or somehow
interfering with the central dogma so in
this video we would look at how
antibiotics can interfere with
transcription how that process could be
used in molecular biology or in medicine
so let's just first revise the concept
of transcription a little bit then we
move to the antibiotics part so we know
in case of eukaryotes there is a basal
transcription factors like TF to
families all these tf2 families bind the
promoter and help to recruit the
eukaryotic RNA polymerase one component
of these initiation complex for
transcription is transcription factor 2
HR tf2h which actually phosphorylate the
c-terminal domain of the RNA pol - now
this tf2h also has a helicase activity
it has a phosphorylase and a helicase
activity once the c-terminal domain is
phosphorylated it gives the trans the
RNA pol as a start signal to move along
the DNA and transcribing the mRNA right
now let's look at how several
antibiotics interfere with these process
of making RNA from DNA first we'll talk
about actin amaizing D here is a
structure of actin amaizing D it's like
a pretty flattering which can get
incorporated in between the DNA based
acts and that can work like a
transcription block so here you can see
how the acronym is endearing gets fit
between GC base pairs so it's work like
a road bump a huge one so when the RNA
polymerase 2 is moving all across the
DNA and trying to transcribe it it phase
this roadblock and it has to stop there
so the transcription is inhibited at in
a premature state that is how actually
my cindy works
now activist indi is very important in
context of biological research imagine
let's say you you have actin amaizing
and let's see what you can do so let's
say you found that these cells if you
give them a magic chemical which you
have isolated from some source let's say
they would really show change in their
cell division kinetics and they would
show increased proliferation now you
want to understand that what are the
molecular process that leads to this
physical change the proliferation
phenotype so you would think about okay
transcription could be a reason trans
the translation could be a reason post
translational modification could play a
role in these but let's say you have a
specific question that transcription is
important for that in order to
understand that what you can do is add
actin amaizing D to plug the
transcription and then see when you
block the transcription you have effect
or not so if transcription has a role if
it is yes then blocking like then adding
this magic chemical with the combination
of actin oh my Cindy would prevent the
proliferation then you can clearly at
least say at a superficial level that
transcriptional readout or
transcriptional process is involved in
this proliferation that you see and that
is how it is used widely in molecular
biology field so as it can block
transcription some of the cases it is
also used as anti-cancer etc because it
can block transcription and it would
mostly affect the cells which are
rapidly transcribing a lot of products
such as the cancer cells yeah there are
side effects because many other human
cells like host cells could also get
affected by this process now let's talk
about accreting which is another
substance which can block transcription
reading can basically step in between
the base pairs of the DNA and that's how
it can block transcription an accident
is used in biology to stain RNA and DNA
and that is how it can be detected under
fluorescence microscopy so it's also
used in other
research methods right let's talk about
refund pissing refund pacing is very
specific to the prokaryotic RNA
polymerase it is not specific for
eukaryotic RNA polymerases it is
eukaryotic RNA polymerase is not
sensitive to rifampicin rifampicin can
bind to the beater - subunit subunit of
the prokaryotic partner polymerase and
it holds that RNA polymerase there and
reduce its promoter clearance
probability once the promoter is not
cleared abortive transcription can
happen and short length mRNAs would be
generated which would not give rise to a
functional protein and that's how the
bacteria would be take so that is how we
thumb pissing interacts with interferes
with the transcription process by
directly binding with the beta subunit
of prokaryotic RNA polymerase now
rifampicin
do not affect the eukaryotic RNA
polymerase it it turns out the
eukaryotic RNA polymerase has different
very low binding affinity with Compeyson
and that's why it is resistant now
refocusing as it can really interfere
selectively the RNA polymers of bacteria
it is used as antibacterial agent
especially for tuberculosis Beckham
pissing is used as a drug in combination
with many other antibiotics now let's
talk about one of the most important
antibody biotic which is known as alpha
immunity which is actually obtained from
a Manisha fellow this mushroom which is
also known as a death mushroom now this
alpha amanitin has a selective property
that it selectively bind to eukaryotic
RNA pol - sorry for that it's sweetener
and a poor one but it selectively binds
to eukaryotic RNA pol - and only at
higher concentration of laminating bind
to eukaryotic RNA pol three but
eukaryotic RNA polymerase one and
prokaryotic RNA polymerase are totally
resistant to alpha amanitin
clearly you can understand that alpha
amanitin could be used to selectively
block transcription in eukaryotes right
but it would save spare than you ProCare
your counterparts because prokaryotic
RNA polymerase is not at all sensitive
for T's so that's pretty much it we
discussed several more of action of
several antibiotics and how especially
they can interact and interfere with the
process of transcription so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
don't forget to leave your comment at
the end of this video your comment give
me so much positive motivation to make
more such videos thank you see you next
time